hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Fatal Frame 2 now in
the last episode we got an item and it
was a map that I accidentally skipped
through because I was spamming the
button like a like a me there's really
no other way to explain that than other
than to me and it points to an exit so
basically I need to go back into the
Kurosawa House which I checked with a
map was where I was before I was were
than I was Kurosawa second floor so
somewhere in here there is another way
out if I can just compare the map to
what I'm seeing here so I yeah there was
a staircase in relation to it hodkin
that stopped for once
this reminds me all the five nights at
Freddy's games that I've been through
all the knockoff ones so it's something
of that but that doesn't make any sense
because I don't know what that is like
that doesn't look like anything that
I've seen in the map of where I am right
now this is on the first floor guess
maybe wait no here's our first floor
maybe that doesn't make any sense either
because I would just mean there was come
through here and then the goons and
dunno where that door lead huh I don't
know I don't know okay so either way I'm
just gonna keep exploring I'm sure that
it will kind of get me environmental
clues by monsters jumping out of me
things trying to steal my soul neo being
a great big creeper over there may be
just one around
I'm scared alone lost little girl scared
alone don't have to care of her in the
world and then possibly these demons
ashes are gonna come alive but there had
to be in something else because I just
solved the puzzle to let myself go
through for all the puppet dolls God me
oh my you whatever and I need to find a
way to get that no I need to find a way
to get the excuse me I need to find a
way to get to that out of it
I know there is I know I know I know
darling
I know Wow it's gonna be okay I know Wow
turning is not my strong suit over here
okay so maybe because there was a bit of
a staircase right here
there might be something up oh oh you
Saints of the shell oh you didn't just
see the but okay whatever man-- these
I'm glad because this game assumes that
I'm an idiot and needs to point out
everything seems like it fell through
the hole in the ceiling Oh does that
mean the blue dot is still there maybe I
could use this through the blue dot and
Lulu let's see if this area kind of
doesn't exactly match that goes back uh
that way there's another door here that
is to the courtyard where I originally
was but I don't know why I would need to
leave the kurosawa room her house
because I could just leave the front
door
couldn't I but anyway let me see if like
I don't know if the item is still there
or if it oh it's still up there so if I
take this ball and roll it down into the
thing maybe then I'll be able to get it
but then again where did this ghost ball
come from not that kind of ghost ball
don't be a weirdo maybe it would come
loose if you drop the ball onto it
hey that's a good idea let's not even
make the choice yay I got the thing
looks like the object that was caught
dropped with the ball to the floor below
thank you for meeting very obvious you
know I'm actually trying to overthink
this game I'm actually not giving it
justice by just letting it guide me to
where I need to go I'm trying to think
it much too much cuz that's what one
thing everybody knows that's one thing
that markiplier does too much and that's
think too much diamond linky oh well
okay well that's right down the way here
this is being convenient this is not
having me run around in circles over and
over and over again like I know that it
could even though I continue to run
around in circles over and over and over
again but that's this weekend up I'm a
little special just a little bit
wait was it that one that doors stuck
fast with a giant monster behind it cuz
this looks like the runnin hallway of a
giant monster chasing me kind of feel oh
no wait it's just me you may I me I run
Miami I'm an unlocked it with the
diamond link key okay let's not be too
[ __ ] here it's very calmly could be
all sorts of monstrosity is inside there
let me change out before people get mad
at me I'm gonna change out to the seven
film so that I can take pictures of
anthem or any random thing that pops out
of me time by right Rancic
oh god dang it I always panic I pull
down the other stick I knew there's
gonna be something aah
I failed you guys I failed you guys you
put all your faith in me oh wait no you
didn't okay screw then I could have done
it maybe don't screw you no bleeding no
I'm sorry this is once again we're on
the roller coaster of emotion that
doesn't make any sense to anybody other
than me
hi what's your name Dom yeah
Oh check it the picture I got you
captive oh I guess weren't going
anywhere okay that one that one is a bit
more forgiving long ago a visitor to a
mountain village became a ceremonial
sacrifice when the veil priest captured
me they said things like outsider and
kusabi
what exactly is the nature of the hidden
ceremony as they're stabbing me you know
heard it writing down the key the twin
girls game he must be for the side door
to the house the key for the cell must
be in another house according to the map
the key is hidden in the cave under the
Osaka House maybe this is in the cellar
in the passageway that I read about okay
so that's him is that my you is that my
you stepping all over me while I'm
trying to read an important thing it is
okay thanks bye you okay
my you what are you doing wait what send
up my
okay two padlocks on the cell door
symbol of light and shadow my you what
are those things totally quiet jumper
though
my please tell me that's my was that my
you is that some else I don't know if he
was something else I supposed to pay
attention to or not this game I just
don't understand I think it was just her
stuck by the doorway or at least I'd
like to think okay so is that the only
thing that I need to get from here
couldn't have been oh I haven't been up
that one okay there's another way to go
up here over this way no time to leave
yet need to go through for another ghost
eager that's gonna pop out of me I need
to film you I'll get you don't worry
just hang on need get focus clinging
shadow looks like an awful sha solid
shadow there don't worry I got your back
my irimi oh whatever
sorry just need to slow you down a
little bit apparently all right come on
come on sister of mine probably twin
sister of mine somehow very tangentially
related to the twin sisters in the past
where one went psychotic and murdered
everybody and opened a portal to Hell
but she got possessed by a demon I don't
like this where are we going down into
the basement oh this is the basement
that it was just talking about the
folklore was literally just talking
about this wasn't it
excuse me I just decided to go the
opposite way of what I wanted to go just
to mix things up you know this movie
some boobies gonna happen here
come on spit me spoot me hard spook me
hardies all right oh I'm just lost
where where who does what oh that's not
it I got it no no don't slow down there
but you're okay all right stop just get
out please thank you keep change Phil
says don't be mumbling at me I ain't
ready for your mumbles I'm ready done
exercise you where where is it
whoo hey they're yours oh look it's a
three huh what
I gotcha oh no mr. crazy man what are
you doing oh nothing that's great good
for you yeah let me do it again what
you're gonna let me do it again
but I was gonna be high damage but I'm
gonna get you don't worry I want to get
you know who you think you'd be smiling
with all your powers let's say World of
Warcraft Bob this you and me is you and
me craft is you and me bow wow it is
hard oh god laughs no don't you don't do
you big boy unity not much better than
it was last time I could have gotten
another shot in there I think where is
he where's knockout where's he where's
of course yeah yeah thanks for helping
my mural
where is it where's I don't see him
where is he
whoa I thought I saw Oh God aah what
happening without me where's oh god he's
a whirlybird
God why is he a Wimbley whoa where's he
going
oh [ __ ] hey Rick
whoa there you are okay I'm a-comin for
you I know the ritual the ritual then
you I got your face got another one ah I
almost had a double hit we try to slow
this guy down slow down
No damn it where is he now
think you might have still been there he
just kind of went a little invisible
but now I hear a voice over here well Oh
what oh he did go invisible that dick
that douchebag how dare you lay a finger
on me gross to you so he is here
oh there you hey buddy guess what BAM
I'll get you another one
cuz apparently gives me another
opportunity or not not not not good -
okay you'll stand satphone that's all he
fine - I hear you why girl double kill
all in one at once whoa I see you oh
crap a seat oh crap I see that I see all
of that oh there you are hey guess what
you're have to go back outta hell arid
orb cool get upgrade my camera I'll be
so good for me man these encounters
lasts quite a long time I mean I know
I'm not using my most powerful stuff the
square mouth of the old well gapes open
stood arc to see inside to the bottom
yeah is it the well from 300 that he
kicked the dude into is this all madness
is this sparta I don't even know okay
now you have a bit of an upgrade and we
have a way to go like I gotta admit like
I don't actually need to worry about
exploring all that much just because the
game actually guides me now what I do
imagine is that there's a lot of Easter
Egg type hidden stuff that reveals more
of the story if I know my Japanese
horror games and I know that exactly
what's gonna sand the surface of it and
who knows maybe there's multiple endings
to this game I mean it doesn't usually
happen but there's a hammer design
engraved on the panel well damn it must
lead outside you feel cold wind yeah why
but didn't I just go back through the
front door
yes I think we can leave here [ __ ]
switch back to my other films so
everybody that elitist fatal frames
blared will be very sad as I did what
I'm doing now come along come along
sister let's skip to our lose skip away
really do oh this is a big empty
corridor what was the point of coming
down here other than fighting the priest
ghost unless what I really needed was
just that spirit orbit that one moment
has to be something else like a can of
wandered around him
alright the creepy talked really really
we we spoke about this before the
episode ended last time and after the
episode ended last time you gotta cut it
down man bruh bruh bruh sister of mine
bro bro sis sis bro God come on yeah
stop being so creepy so where am I
supposed to go now this was this was a
basement area the other end of the
hallway there was nothing else there and
I didn't have the potato padlock so that
means that I had to have to go back I
guess I mean oddly enough I know there's
a lot of going back and forth but it did
guide me to this point there's really no
other way I could have gone it was like
staring me in the face like dude there's
something in the crack in the spiderweb
oh here's a ball to get the thing in the
crack in the spiderweb why don't you use
that ball on the thing in the crack in
the spiderweb so that you can get the
thing in the crap inspire web okay what
else we need it's gotta be something I'm
missing something I'm missing
what am I missing maybe behind that
alcove there was something there
yeah let me just double check you never
know with these things no not that way
just yet excuse me thanks for catching
up finally that's over yay 61 film
that's pretty powerful it's too dark to
see inside why isn't my flashlight
working anymore why can't I have my
flashlight can I use that
damn it sure is like a button the uses
that brings out the flashlight maybe No
damn it okay but select brings up the
map so that's convenient
nope just a whole lot of nothing hold on
uh all right okay whatever then fine
I'll go back the way I came
service now this is a two padlocks with
the light and shadow I don't have light
and shadow so I don't imagine that
there's anything that I can actually do
there uh I'll be right back cuz I don't
know where I'm going
oh wait um yeah it's your ritual but
don't you be pushing the rituals on me
hey hi I'm an impressionable young lady
you'll leave me the hell alone how can I
go through that door now also I can go
through that door now that what you
saying
I can definitely go through that door
the door is open
no it's not you are mistaken in this
endeavor you are wrong I must point out
how wrong oh oh this looks fun
oh this looks like the fun run oh god
damn it
now you I'm gonna use my more powerful
film because I have some here we go
hello you're so pretty and now you
okay god dammit why
okay can I at least get it you know a
good shot what what hey what are you
doing oh I see it's like a timing thing
like well that wasn't hardly any more
damage at all alright fine you know when
I'm going to oh there's guy behind me
whoa whoa wait whoa wait whoa whoa okay
hang on thick I'm going back to my type
fourteen because it's it's almost
exactly the same it's a matter of
fighting a little bit less Oh what are
you gonna do here a new friend but
gotcha wait does that my you gosh you
double shot double chat to it combo baby
okay that was awesome
I felt good about that I'm actually
learning I can do things I'm gonna hit
combo you so good oh [ __ ] where are you
whereas a cube I hear you
whoa-ohh why are you over there over
there and another rap oh god damn it
sigh it's really finicky on that really
fitting oh this great camera angle
Thanks
okay what is this I'm just gonna
interrupt
it's just combat whatever I'll read a
book the malleus coming from the park is
getting stronger I've searched and
there's no record of her getting the
strong in the past recently poor
harvests and deaths have become dooms
crease the time of repentance for
Tachibana's failure to perform the
ritual is drawing near half of the
mourners were driven bad by the mouse
and jumped into the blog we must prepare
more mourners will use the sinners if we
don't do something the long will
overflow in a few years I must use my
daughters in the ritual saying hey must
be cleanse for the village all right
then why not just move teased weirdo
whole berries
I got him a random aware to you old area
hey buddy hey how you doing you look
good man I'm gonna get to it come on you
oh come on why sometimes in some not
times yeah hit me hit me baby let me
baby one more time
Oh another gal oh come on I think's for
getting in my way
hello
don't despair honey yes fatal frame oh
he's dead
no combo needed just fall over slump
slump slump and you're done all right
there we go right back into the creepy
stuff am i you right back in because we
just talked about this we just talked
about design I don't think we're ever
gonna stop talking about this saying ray
saying yay ran away with that boy and
remaining the kusabi calmed a little bit
but it's still rumbling if the twins
aren't brought back the village will be
swallowed by the GAR they are my
daughters
I must find them you must find them to
sacrifice them that's great
very responsible parenting of you does
an incense burner filled with ashes on
the shelf okey-dokey good for it
excuse me sorry is that thunder or a
gunshot yeah who cares what else cool is
going on here
there's something I should know Oh
herbal medicine exactly what I needed I
needed some fresh herbs to come to use
me some fresh herbs to calm down oh wait
no Matt this place it looks nothing like
the clue I was giving this is totally
useless to me all right let's go up no
let's not spin around let's not
pirouette it's not dance like a
ballerina let's go up the stairs tart
destiny
Hey look at that it's a thingy I'm gonna
get that thingy oh boy the C powerup
lens
okay finds a location of a spirit all
right extends duration all right
displays location monster okay so what I
figured it I I did some thinking it's
like each of these power-ups is
something that can take the triangle
button and you switch them out based on
what you think you need at a time
whether you want to slow them down find
where they are or whatever the other one
was so while this effective active the
spirit is easier to locate this is
especially effective against spirits
that vanished for extended periods of
time yes please
dear goodness that's like the most best
hi my you how are you doing how are you
doing oh great sister of mine okay so
this means that what I can do is I can
switch out special functions to other
stuff
but not right now how can I do that
ozs be yeah I got that oh oh oh I need
oh okay
so what I need to do is I need to do I
like blast that sounds good
does it take so long to kill him all
right let's get blasting all right okay
okay cool so if I can get blast that
means I can equipped blast I can't
change it out I guess I don't know no
that's got to be it but I don't know why
I don't get I just so confusing to me
this I get games I play games a long
time I play good games oh oh okay
duh in the equip function I'm a dingus
I'm a dum-dum everybody ignore me please
hi you stepped on the pattern on the
floor you felt it sink down a little bit
hey my you stay right here right there I
was already uh I've already wait thanks
my you I'm just gonna leave you now
because hey it's been great but gotta
move on can leave the nest the time of
the ritual is coming soon
Itsuki and Mizuki's ritual didn't work
this year it's our turn I'm leaving the
village with you
Itsuki will help us escape and we'll be
together forever like I promised yay the
truth is I don't want to run as long as
I can be with you I'll follow you in
anywhere just don't leave me here alone
say maybe like they're not different
maybe they're the same maybe we are
those people maybe we are just 21 apiece
who knows it's all mystery that's what
the great part of the game is ok bye
forever I was wrong it's just like
Itsuki said
Munakata teacher is going to be ok this
has to stop
people like Mizuki shouldn't have to die
I have to do something a veiled priest
took one of the cells keys to the rope
temple yay
it seems father plans to make that mana
but even though he's moon taught us
teacher I know one cell key is hidden
the father's bookshelves to keep them
appeased there's only one thing to do if
we perform the crimson sacrifice perhaps
people won't suffer like this right then
how was I supposed to get the call oh
damn it God okay Han hang on wait no
hang on wait no hang on I was using tie
14 hang on
you gone BAM
gotcha get the back of you get the butt
back here what are you doing Oh Jeb did
I not get it you hold on to your gasps
hold on to your what so you're telling
me that I need to get this key off your
corpse what did that say I was I wasn't
even present on anything I just press it
once what did that ah did that say
what a dick what a dingus okay so either
way I need to go back to the Masters
room is what that's saying or I needed
to go to whatever the hell room is here
either way I need to go no I need to go
to the master room because it's in a
book shelf somewhere damn it it was
British pride just telling me that I
needed to go over there do the thing and
whatever is my you still gonna be there
oh uh hi yeah you volunteered for that
position don't act like all high and
mighty that I made you do that even
though I exactly did that thing and said
that separation was good for the whole
family but ignore all that we're just
gonna pretend like that didn't happen
and move on with our lives
this wasn't here before glowing red
crystal oh boy another radio adventure
I remember how well this one last Simon
is going to be a lot of fun spirit orb
perfect now you are Nitin Hey okay Oh oh
yeah I forgot it hi resaved after all
this so faintly glowing crystal copy
oh damn goose Abbi I'm sorry that damn
kusabi
ritual Europe oh sorry
these will be ah
huh okay that's not the one that I just
picked up I think this is the one
okay on the same Vegas y'all got it
sorry I'm young
she didn't want to die
ah not about ears man geez don't be
moaning like that in my ears we've laid
down some ground rules here no moaning
in my ear jeez okay so all hell broke
loose quite literally in this place and
it's all because you're a runaway ran
run run away okay so I need to go back
to the altar room which was mm-hmm
where why it wasn't down that way was it
cuz that just led to the basement wasn't
in the warehouse God could this pointer
be nice huh storage room where was oh it
was upstairs from the storage room and
then I went around okay I got I got I
got I got I gotta getta getta getta
getta getta getta getta getta getta DD I
got it I got it I got it I get it I get
it I get it together together together a
little and then up here I believe anyway
I'm pretty sure this is the way it went
and then yeah because there was a door
hidden behind here that did the thing
went to the other room
over who pray tell who's near
don't know why I'm walking headfirst
into this room does that mean when you
say you create the kusabi sure wish I
knew what that one blip of information
said before it went away oh wait no I
don't need to get there I don't need to
get there I need to get here because
here's where I saw that guy was doing
something on these maybe goodies oh no
come on you oh you can't be serious here
taboo some the cattell is called haha
gazed on upon the who Isaac Clemson's
where I will be blinded by the moon
please beat not of them the mouth which
others can will be made speechless light
of time listen not to the king
those who heed the hour turn heartless
by the well glad I picked up that tab
you Tom there's some empty bookshelves
above the Buddha writings inscribed on
the wood engrave the crimson butterfly
to see off the car if there are no
sacrifice repented with a kusabi what so
kusabi is that sacrifice that word for
sacrifice
this was the bookshelf that I thought it
was mentioning but apparently not Sasser
tom oh boy if the ritual is not
performed the pineal will open in human
wrenches shell burst forth from the
where the villagers will be engulfed by
the pea and the sky will be plunged into
darkness the darkness will spread over
the land for generations awakened all
and then everyone will die we must think
of this disaster as a repentance for our
failure to fulfill our duty to the blue
which grants us life we must accept that
this is the reason for our existence
okay so they just live in this town
because oh there was another one in the
crimson sacrifice ritual the shrine
maidens become one again they become a
deity tupiza whoo the ladder she'll stay
here watching over the human world the
first shall pass through to the bull
calming the earth all right so that's
why twins are needed cuz they're one in
the same they list in the same plane
while being two individuals they can
cross over to the spirit world
and yet remain connected so that they
are not lost okay so I really wish I
didn't somehow skip the doodads cuz if I
didn't skip the doodads I wouldn't have
to be wandering round it not knowing
what I was supposed to do it just
skipped it it wasn't my fault wasn't
that I didn't yet I did not hit her like
it had okay so it wasn't that way it was
obviously not the dullest and room like
the thing it went from the meditation
room to here like I got the vision of
the guy from across here so it had to
been in the masters room like it
couldn't have been anywhere else let me
just save her excuse me I didn't even
see you there
almost like you're a figment of my
imagination and I'm the special one
maybe I'm a figment of my own
imagination
no-one's a special one that's wrong cuz
you're the special one to me yeah it's
so happy everyone's dying or everyone
died a long time ago I guess I'm not
really dying anymore than dead all right
so it's gotta be no not to me do it
correctly no it's got to be in the room
somewhere excuse me excuse me excuse me
we got him here to stop your skidding
emo I think you want the pause that
happened that's what you would like a my
you my you my luggage back
the sister dynamic is not working for me
okay so holds a tiny key in its hand so
do I need to put the books back in there
is that what is that what this is going
on
crimson wing tone shrine maiden's of the
past and future made in crimson
butterflies return to the war as
guardians of the village those that
become butterflies ascend to heaven
parting the skies above inviting the
light upon us
great okay yes we know accept us it's
not our fault shut up okay there are we
okay III oh man that was my own
ignorance because I wasn't paying
attention like I was so confused of the
fact that I thought I would just get
something that I didn't realize that I
needed to pick a woman my bad my bad
please yell at me for the I will allow
you this is your time you have ten
seconds to yell at me profusely in the
comments below please do also mean oh
you say that uh oh it's okay oh god why
okay Laurie
okay so I'll just have to put the book
on uh disaster dummy how am I supposed
to know which one these are supposed to
be uh is there like a clue
what wait wait wait a minute wait a
minute
how much both know how much both know
what you want me to do so what
Kabuto this is gonna be guests this is
gonna be guesswork isn't it
let's see what this does nothing happens
gray cool maybe there was a uh oh there
we go engrave the crimson butterfly to
seal up if you are there's no sacrifice
repent with the kusabi thank you okay so
now that I read that I can actually do
what I need to do so if I do this
there's got to be clues in this book I'm
gonna fast forward cuz it's gonna take a
while BRB oh okay oh the red
highlighting is in the same in the book
it's the red highlighting in the book
okay uh yeah I got it okay crimson
butterfly star sacrifice repent kusabi
so I think I actually because actually
right bam twin tome am ritual tone easy
enough heard something locked
beneath the behind the bookshelves okay
got it got it got it got it I did it a
key felt in the statute dance yes key
for light I need the key for shadow now
and then I would have them what do you
what have him doing like why would you
do this you're just causing me emotional
distress okay from behind the bookshelf
sit behind the bookshelf who did the
front door unlock I think the front door
unlocked maybe because the floor down
direct blows as it's gonna be but I
don't know okay so I have the light key
but I do not have the Shaoqi so that's
it's kind of a problem kind of any bit
of an issue like what am I supposed to
do about the hi actually let me go back
to the other way because I think no it
would be quicker to go this way
wrong-o wrong-o wrong-o boom okay you
stay back now I know that probably
didn't hurt you very much not even a
little bit okay hang on wait hang on I
gotta change film god you're you're
pressuring me I don't like it just a
couple of years apps whatever whatever
just whatever God let me get my camera
geez BAM
Fatal Frame oh that hurt me instead I
planned that whatever just whatever
whatever man whatever I'm gonna blast
you I'm gonna blast you I'm not gonna
feel good plan oh god damn it is that
baloney was that malarkey found out
glasses blast him I blasted him to 20
hole damage cousin frickin went wrong
just give me your gosh dang thing
ma'am gotcha I need to do it with the
trigger because I'm like trying to move
and angle it and I'm not like I have to
move my finger to the button look as
soon as it's ready damn - too soon too
soon
I'm a blast this guy out of hell
come on come on I'll go after her okay
don't go after bam blasted you so hard
oh hey six damage on no one's done that
noscope [ __ ] oh hi
well I was celebrating you don't seem
very happy for my victory Thanks yeah
thank you I don't know if like the cap
of film is at 99 or something but I
think I need to start using 14 film
because I was right I have a lot of it
and I'm gonna be fine for it and then I
save all my powerful stuff for the more
powerful ghosts we're never using
reaching into the game with so much film
that it doesn't even matter okay so I
have a light key but I need another one
was there something else in that room
that I missed that unlocked because if
there is I will be very upset I'd like
to think there wouldn't be but you never
know the only thing I can do is keep
going I think I might be able to get out
now is it if my theory is correct then
we think oh really I didn't walk through
the door because your stupid directional
didn't put you in the right motion what
ever breath oh hi we come go don't go
don't go get in my circle get in my
circle legs didn't even get in my circle
it didn't even get a mic going up oh
yeah I'm a dog try pushing on the into
countless handprints on the door damn it
I was wrong I gotta go back ding dong or
damn ass dingus damn store after I be
damned get near okay let me just because
I have the light key maybe it wants me
to go back to the thing and put the
white light key in and that way I can
get the shadow key later I think that's
my only assumption maybe it's like trail
of bread comes very red boys
breadcrumbs excuse me sorry Freudian
slip if you know what I mean anyway
trail that I just got to follow possibly
it's gonna give me the right answer once
I get out of here oh hey whoa hey whoa
hey hey what's going on me behind behind
this curtain and ain't gonna save you
get your picture taken we're not here
now what about about a little bit for
you are you hiding behind us
oh I got your attention now huh my back
oh yeah
special shot 88 dabble it up in your
face used up all my spirit orbs but it
doesn't matter this is a little weird
close get real close real - really real
rep not that close
oh man I'm almost dead excuse me gross
grabby hands weirdo can finally use one
of my spirit waters thing is sacred one
sorry come back here I got a bone to
pick with you I got a bone to pick with
you I just need to let him walk towards
me because if I back oh don't come okay
good good
if I back up it doesn't allow them to
get close enough like in their normal
animation cycle I can I want sometimes
it's good to back up at other times
hello goodbye thank you for dying stay
in hell okay goodbye okay goodbye
yeah you're dead you're done you're done
you're done yeah that okay so it was
leading me to this place it was if I
just tried it but I'm trying to think
outside the box here I mean you can't
blame me for that I am just a creative
thinker and I have amazing instincts
okay some with light no I have amazing
instincts ah you sassy sassy sassy sooo
haven't made any amazing instincts I
have amazing instincts
I've gamer gamer vision it's gonna be
good for me he'll be real good gonna be
good it's gonna be begging gonna be a
big thing gonna be a great thing maybe
huh I just don't know anymore
hello this is the basement that I was in
where I met the priest for the first
time that sounds a lot creepier than it
is but maybe it is I don't know god damn
it
am I supposed to do I hate being lost
like I know what I need but I just don't
have it another shadow key I don't I
don't know where there's something to
click listen I'm just gonna have to
explore and I have to do I mean if this
doesn't lead to anything I'm gonna pause
it and you guys are gonna catch up at it
hi why were you staring at the camera
did you see that well of course you saw
that what else would you have been
looking at unless you're being
distracted holy crap oh that's right
this had the hammer design poop poop
poop face hoopin face dammit
I was being really creepy I just got the
heebie-jeebies just like looking back at
my I haven't not been paying attention
to my you when she's crossing screens
she's been looking to the camera like
and you guys a lot she gonna do now okay
alright okay I'm like what she's doing
it again she's looking down to the left
she was wasn't she oh my god oh that is
legitimately weird is that just a thing
or is that I am I just imagining it now
Who am I just seeing what I want to see
now not that I want to see that
okay did it just get dark in that
hallway behind me
oh hi Mayu
yeah let's be uh what was that okay I
don't know why but I suddenly got
legitimately creeped out by my you cuz
he's like she's been there the whole
time
but I've never really thought about her
much I'm just reading a surface I will
be back in a second there's gonna be
weird cuz that only yeah I'll be back in
second wait a minute where does this
lead wait have I been here too before
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh
I didn't even see this wait where am I
wait wha a little bit of a secret huh
or maybe not a secret maybe this is what
I was actually supposed to find key
sacred water
good good good I feel good about this
I've got all sorts of good feelings
running through my body it'd be a shame
if you just pulled it out from under me
it's what my creepy sister me and my
creepy sister on a secluded hallway
trying to go home mm-hmm only in the
epicenter of a hell spawn unlike okay
legitimately weirded out why am I here
where is this where I'm supposed to be
Oh trees are lined up between the two
hallways the trees are wet maybe because
of the rain that was falling that'd be a
good assumption
either - what is this since when is this
a thing where am I where the hell when
you stepped on the pattern fell it's
sink a little bit a similar sit on the
other side I wonder if this will open a
stepped off
yes it will we have to split up
unfortunately yeah you stay there Mayu
I'll be right back I sure hope I don't
hear any screams of agony sure hope
nothing bad happens everything's gonna
be just fine
we should literally split up okay
everything's fine no I felt a sink down
a little Missy to unlock the door yeah
didn't we promise oh Jesus remedy
Christmas BAM
geez what I'm waiting no kidding how
long were you there for
geez you're sorry for what did you make
that ghost happen hi anyway I'm all out
of time for this episode I'm still
thoroughly enjoying myself I mean I'm
getting lost every once in a while I
could be going through this a bit
quicker than I am but hey is what it is
I am what I am
I'm proud that so thank you all so much
for supporting me thank you so much for
berating for you me for my mistakes keep
the comments coming I'm still gonna be
reading but obviously I've been
recording in a bit of a batch session I
may do one more episode after this well
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always I will see you
I'm wrong and they're just everywhere
okay here's the bridge
wait no did I cross this room wait is
this the same bridge wait a minute I was
going on then it's like Oh locked on
target
good god I'm gonna murder him